[Music]
hi
i will good morning or good day wherever
you are in the world today
is our um something very special this
i kind of had a hard time sleeping last
night i was part nervous
and part excited to be presenting this
to you all today
this is the first time we are doing the
essay workshop in webinar format
and i just wanted to make sure that
today whatever we did
i was able to help make this process
feel at least a little bit more
approachable
and help you feel good about what you're
going to be
putting down should you be applying to
the gsp in business school in the future
so today we're going to use the what
matters most to you and why
essay as kind of that foundation for our
conversation
and from there we're going to zoom out a
little bit and talk about you know the
application as a whole
we do practice a holistic review process
where
we take a look at everything that you
submit and no one piece is necessarily
more important than another but each
does
function in a slightly different way and
so we'll get to that a little bit later
so what we're going to cover is
a few things over the course of today's
session
first we're going to set that stage how
do we think about
and approach at least today's time
together
from there i do have a writing exercise
so be prepared
um to put a little bit of investment in
today's
um event from there we'll zoom out
and really talk about writing as a whole
in the
application and then definitely i want
to make sure that we have enough time
for
questions and answers and discussion um
i would like to preview that
we might not get to everybody's
questions today so if there's anything
else that you would like to ask
or if you have questions that arise over
the course of this week
please feel free to contact us at the
mba admissions office
and i'd like to put a plug this friday
we are having an ask an ao
session where really we're really going
to be focusing on the questions that
matter to you
so let's actually start with
a little bit of a disclaimer so there
are
a lot of people out there there are a
lot of sources
out there that with advice or hear
something that you should do
here's what got me in and i want to say
that whatever is out there take it with
a grain of salt
including the things that you hear today
adapt the feedback that you feel like is
most
relevant to you and maybe put the other
stuff in your back pocket to mull over
for another day or another situation
the last thing i want for today to do is
amp up the stress or make you feel more
anxious
about what's to come so hopefully this
is just
another perspective on a way to approach
the essays and not necessarily
this is what you have to do explicitly
so hopefully
some great takeaways but no hard and
fast rules today
all right so getting to that stage and
setting up today
just mentioned there's a lot of things
like
out there um and here is a time
that you actually get to hear about some
answers
and responses straight from the horse's
mouth
all for free so take a moment and think
about some of the things you've heard
whether it's rumors or um just kind of
a question that you might have go ahead
and pop those into the q a box
my colleagues are going to help me
collate some of these i'm gonna stop
screen sharing so that i can actually
put
some of your questions and things that
you've heard
onto the slide and i'll adapt today's
session
to be able to address as many of these
questions and comments as possible
and then at the end we'll return and
make sure to see that we've um
checked in on each one of those elements
as you're thinking and typing through
that we're going to be doing our writing
exercise next
so if you need to go ahead and grab
stand up
find a pen pencil paper maybe you want
to type on another screen
or if none of those are available to you
feel free to go ahead and just know that
as you sit in you might just need to do
a little bit more
tracking of thoughts in your head but
there's no
right or wrong way to do this i
personally find that it's often helpful
to have some of that um
tactile stimulus of writing to both slow
me down
and allow me the moments to really um
let those thoughts simmer
so i'm gonna stop sharing for a moment
and we are going to turn to the q and a
box
all right here we go
and so for my colleagues who are here on
the line
are there any themes that um you see
emerging
question here is there a type of minimum
information or specific structure okay
um got capslock on
what types of information
should i include great thank you diego
for that
um
let's see here ah here's a great
question from siva
um application material used for
interview short listing or part of the
final assessment itself
so i'll talk about um how we use the
application material as part of a
holistic review process
awesome
keep keep those questions coming
ah for re-applications tips on um how to
approach the application then
for those reapplying to the gsb
there's a question about um in the past
in test scores and how do we think about
that
maybe it's a low gpa and so i'll excuse
me
i'll make sure to fold that into the
holistic review process
ah here's a question about um i think
it's similar to that element on
um structure or types of information
what
what's to fluff quote unquote fluffy
and under that umbrella i'll also
include um
what if it's something that's
controversial
all right
all right so go ahead and keep those
questions coming
i have a few here i'm going to invite my
colleagues to continue collating and
then later on i'll check in with them as
well
they'll be sending me some of these over
chat um and i'll continue to incorporate
those
through today so i'm gonna go back into
screen share
so that we can continue with the session
all right so i do have captured here a
few of the things that i've been seeing
pens and paper all right i hope you're
ready
so let's write so take a moment
and whatever pops into your head first
i want you to go ahead and write this
down for the prompt it doesn't have to
be
too deep but more so just for the sake
of this exercise
what matters to you okay
so go ahead and jot something down i'm
actually gonna go
off screen so that my shiny bobble head
doesn't distract you too much i want you
to be able to
concentrate on this exercise so
what matters to you
all right so i'm going to give you a
couple of moments
and so now that you have that thing or
topic or whatever that is
write down why i'll give you a few
moments for that
all right for each one of these sections
i'm going to give you a little bit more
time just to give you
an opportunity to be really thoughtful
about it
so you answered what matters to you and
you gave a reason why
why that so let's say
um you said uh your dog matters to you
first thing that i saw right in front of
me today um
dog matters to me because they remind me
there are
other things and people in my life to
live for
and then that next level why might be
something along the lines of
it helps ground me in the here and now
so
let's start getting into some of these
deeper layers give you some time to
think about that
all right one more time you're going to
ask yourself
why that
all right i think you have a pretty good
sense of what i'm going to ask you
next why that
and one final time why that
all right so i'm going to rejoin you
here and so i can't claim to
be the originator of this framework i
know many of you out there might be
using it already in your professional
realms
um some spaces it's called the five wise
um and this is an exercise that you can
use to help kind of
understand and dig deeper into some of
the things that
really matter to you this is a great
exercise in case you find yourself
stuck or you just want to go through the
exercise and practice of being able to
put to words
um the things that you know inside
just feel very immediate but are
sometimes
hard to articulate um to those around
you so
definitely encourage putting um practice
of putting words to those feelings and
so we did a pretty fast forward version
of it here
but it's more just to illustrate one of
the many things that you can do through
this process
so what we're gonna do is really now
connect that
back and if you think about it
what are the essays for need to think
about that in terms of
what is the job of an admissions officer
so
what is my job and so
yes it's to read applications but what
about them am i looking for
so we're looking at three broad topics
here
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential and personal
qualities and contributions
and so i'm not going to go into too much
detail here
we host information sessions throughout
the year and you can always ask us about
it the ask an ao session on friday
um and if you haven't done so already i
like to direct folks to the mba
admissions website
under admissions criteria there's some
like
some pretty awesome language about each
one of these topics
for intellectual vitality there's um
rhetorical questions so you can get a
sense for how intellectual vitality
might come to life for you and in the
case of demonstrated leadership
potential
we actually list some of the many
leadership competencies that exist out
in the world
but back to the here and now and
understanding my job
these are the things that i'm looking
for in your application
and yes some of them might be more
centered in some areas so intellectual
vitality you know sometimes in the
classroom
some testing goes into that but that
actually kind of speaks broadly across
the whole range
i can find elements of each one of these
almost anywhere in your application
and so what i want you to think about is
this
we're gonna take a little bit of an
existential timeout
let's come back to this california happy
place
um because i want you to sit and think
if my job as an admission officer is to
get a sense of those three things and
figure out who you are
how you're going to show up in our
classrooms and in our community
i think the question we should be asking
ourselves and question you should be
asking yourself is
who are you
okay so this is
not just i don't mean this facetiously
but if you think about
whether it's elements of your upbringing
who you are maybe there's visible or
invisible
parts of your identity the intersection
of different elements of your identity
how do those shift relative to
how you move through the world these are
some of the questions that
we're going to be asking you at the gsb
these are some of the things that you're
going to be tackling in classes like
lead labs or
interpersonal dynamics where it really
is about okay how do you show up in a
space
the application especially the gsb
application already invites you to
begin this journey and
the first steps on that is trying to get
um at least
an understanding of some of the pieces
that make you who you
are so who are you
and then for as you're embarking on the
application journey itself
how do you share those pieces of
information with us
most effectively and so
back to kind of the three buckets one
more time so
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential and personal
qualities and contributions
you're probably gonna be sick of me
saying those three things by the end of
today's session
but if those are the three things that
stick with you throughout this journey i
have done my job
so where do we learn about these things
you'd be surprised more than just the
essays
i like to think about it as writing
overall
so yes there is a what matters most
essay there's also an
uh an essay about why stanford
there are optional impact questions and
i did see
um some some folks in the q a asking
about those
and those definitely are optional they
are not one of those optional ha ha
where you have to like
fill it out um we have admitted people
who have filled all of them out
we have also admitted folks who did not
fill any of them out or
only filled out one or two of the
optional questions so
when we say optional we really mean
optional
there are other spaces in that
application where you can share with us
a little bit more detail as well
um some folks might think that the
resume and the work history and activity
section
feels redundant um and yeah some of the
things and pieces of information might
be similar
between the two but if you look at the
employment and work history section of
the gsb
application we actually ask you a few
other things there
and you have the opportunity to tell us
a little bit about that role even
so as you think about your resume
and the application you can use those
and juxtapose the types of information
to give us the broadest sense of kind of
the things you do
and what you've been able to accomplish
um
the way that you feel best reflects you
and so as you go through this there's
an ability to really kind of use those
spaces
to best affect i think of the
application as a story of who you are
and every blank space and there is an
opportunity to tell us something new
and so kind of one rule here or one
suggestion i have is
take a moment and look at the different
spaces if you
have a takeaway that is just repeated
elsewhere you know
especially for the optional spaces you
don't need to feel redundant there
but go ahead and think of it and talk
about the same topic
but if you're providing some new take
away or something else i should be
learning about you
because of that you know that could be a
great way to think about those different
spaces
so let's get into some of the tips and
best practices
and these are things that i've collected
having read
tens of thousands of essays over my time
as an admissions professional
these are also things that i've heard
and um kind of worked with some of my
colleagues on
and then for sure i want to spend a lot
of time with the q a box
and returning to some of those questions
that we had earlier
so three tips here so first might seem
kind of basic but answer the question
you would actually be surprised at how
often
i read essays that don't address the
question at hand
and so for us example what matters the
most to you and why
sometimes i'll see instances where folks
will say
we'll just continue writing and by the
end of the essay i actually don't know
what matters of most of them
let alone why um we asked the questions
very intentionally
and um it's been pretty amazing so when
we introduced the optional question
a few years ago or last year um how much
thought went into two lines
so that frame the question how do the
words in the way that they're ordered
how might that land with people how
might that land with folks from
different
contexts whether it's here in the us
international
different professions so there is a lot
of intention
put into the questions that we're asking
and so hopefully
you are responding to those in kind
earlier i mentioned that yes there are
different places in your application you
can tell us different
things about yourself and think yes
definitely
be thoughtful about how you use those
spaces but also
resist the urge to over strategize and
so think i have to put this here
i have to put that there part of the gsb
application is taking the moment to
reflect
to stop and turn inwards and be able to
unpack some of the things that are
important to you
and while it's easy to think about
putting those together for other people
and pleasing others this whole journey
is about
pleasing yourself and i know that might
sound strange for folks
who might have been raised very
differently but the mba journey is an
investment in yourself
and this is less about us at the gsb as
it is
what are the things that you want to
accomplish and then from there how do we
help
you get there so give yourself some of
that room
to evolve adapt and place different
pieces of information
all of these are also pretty flexible so
as you're thinking about what you're
putting where
what's that takeaway you want us to
learn
what do you want us what is that take
away from your what matters so what
matters
why maybe you're telling us a little bit
about your background
what is it from that that i'm supposed
to understand about you
after reading it and then always
remember some questions have
more than one part and so again coming
back to the what matters most to you and
why essay
sometimes you do let me know what
matters most but i don't understand why
sometimes i'll see folks tell us what
matters and they'll provide
evidence for that as opposed to digging
in deep to understand okay what drives
that
um dean moss talks about a body of
research out there who
that demonstrates that some of the most
successful leaders out there are the
ones who
lead from a place of mission and purpose
and value
that's some of those whys behind what
matters so this is an opportunity for
you to already start
uh digging in to understand how those
might shape up for you
all right next kind of realm of tips and
best practices
write for yourself i know that you're
going to be filling out an
application potentially to the gsb
but instead of thinking about what does
will want to read
reframe that as what do i want will
to know about me take power
over the sections of writing let this
application be a celebration of who you
are the things that you've done and what
you want to do next
and there's a lot of stuff out there be
inspired but be yourself
at the end of the day someone who's
written hey
this is the essay that got me into you
know x y or z school
that might be a wonderful piece of
writing that makes sense for them
but trying to overlay that onto your
experience
might actually shortchange you in the
long run
also just kind of between us on this um
webinar um for some of those here's the
essay that got me in
i've been doing this for a while i've
read a lot of applications
and i have seen essays i'm like yes but
i do remember that application and
you know um it was it was helpful in the
holistic review
remember that's just one part of the
entire application
i have also seen essays that have touted
themselves as
the thing that got them in and i can
also phrase it this way
there have been folks who have been
admitted despite their essays
again stanford gsb practice is a
holistic review process
we're looking at all of the different
elements and rather than hanging
a decision on just a section of your
application
it's those three buckets and it's how do
your essays
or your resume your work history your
class work and testing
how do those help us understand those
three things and i'm gonna say one more
time
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential
and personal qualities and contributions
again
as you write for yourself you are the
expert in you
um definitely have some folks take a
take a look at it if you're comfortable
doing so
um to see if you know it really is
reflective of who you are and the
message you want to convey
coming back to those tips from um column
number one
but again sometimes too many cooks can
ruin a dish and too many other people's
opinions
might actually shift the attention away
from the things that really matter to
you
so again i encourage you to go with
whatever you
feel is right for you
and then here we go right with a purpose
there was a question
earlier about what kinds of information
how should i think about the content of
what i'm writing
this is kind of part of it and i'll do a
little bit overview because some of them
are a string through the three so
different schools
have different cultures opportunities um
and as i mentioned at the gsb we're very
intentional about the questions we're
asking in the application
other schools are like i can't speak to
them specifically but i'm sure they are
also
very intentionable intentional about the
questions they're asking
as you think about the things that you
want to do
the way you're going to be able to
engage that might be slightly different
at each of the institutions you're
considering so i definitely recommend
that
yes there might be parts that might be
the same
but go ahead and go through the exercise
of writing it
from scratch for each school carry over
themes if that makes sense for you
but copy and paste is a double-edged
sword and i've seen this go in
so many different ways like um you know
copy and paste can be your best friend
but friends do stab you in the back
every now and then you just
just want to be careful here um so
sometimes with copy and paste there
might be
answered one part of the question maybe
you're not even answering the question
at all even though the spirit might be
there
so again recommend writing things from
scratch
this is also a tip that i would have for
folks who are reapplying
given the time from when you last
applied there could have been a
whole host of things that have happened
to you that haven't shaped the way you
approach the world
um 2020 in particular has had
so many different events that might have
impacted the way you view the world
that you also don't want to shortchange
the growth and the perspective you might
have developed over that time i'm just
using 2020 as an example
but even if the themes are the same
between
the last time you applied and the
current time that you're reapplying
maybe the language you're using is
different and so i definitely encourage
you to
go through the exercise and honor the
process
um of the application um you never know
what other insights that you might
derive about yourself or your goals
um through the process when we're
looking
at re-applicants we are looking at your
application that you submitted
relative to the current application pool
and so while we might have access to
your um
prior application we are basing our
decisions
on what you present in the here and now
and you want to be able to present
the most recent relevant um fresh view
of yourself as possible
all right so while we're on tips and
best practices there was a question
about
what about topics what is too fluffy
maybe even for controversial questions
and i'm gonna say this for us we have no
right or wrong topic material um
rather for you you know this next slide
might actually
be the best thing possible and i frame
this like if you're in doubt
here are two words the really short
question you can ask yourself
to help guide you on you know do i want
to go down this path
um this is actually a question that i
was asked
a lot by my freshman english teacher
that i never knew the power of until
recently
so if in doubt
so what okay regardless of what the
topic material
so for some folks it might feel quote
too vulnerable
for other folks it might be a difficult
circumstance
or um for some folks like that sads
what other folks might call a sad or sob
story
um also how might you approach something
that's controversial
or something very sensitive maybe
possibly like religion
okay i saw some of those themes pop up
through the questions
and so as you approach that think about
so what given that topic
what am i learning about you in the
process
if at the end of that piece of writing i
know more about
your faith then how your faith informs
who you are and the way you move through
the world you might want to go back
and and you know repurpose that a little
bit so i'm learning more about you
um i would say something very similar
for difficult life circumstances
um definitely let us know enough so that
we understand
like the context and situation
but what am i learning about you in our
information session
we use the phrase it all starts with you
and i want to echo that here in the
essays
i want it to revolve and come back to
you
the circumstances in your life the way
you move through the world
elements of your identity inform who you
are and if as you understand those
pieces together
that's going to help us understand you
best so if in doubt
ask yourself so what what are those
takeaways
what do you want us to learn about
through this process
and in doing so there's a couple of
questions here with the themes
about do i need to directly or
explicitly answer the question or can i
take a more implicit approach
um either works so you don't have to say
what matters the most to me is as long
as it's
clear both what and why
um so there is a lot of flexibility
there as well i've seen
all types of forms of communicating
you know that topic or the main takeaway
as long as there's a clear takeaway
okay similar here focus on personal
versus professional
that balance is up to you um the
questions are also very intentional so
what matters the most to you that is
very open-ended
and that does not necessarily have to be
professional that said maybe there are
professional elements that you
want to let us know about that you're
especially proud of we want you to let
us
we want you to do that as well and that
might be where the optional questions
come into play
we want to be able to separate both the
things that
are kind of intrinsic to who you are
while still providing the space to
learn about you know what are the
impacts that you might have had
uh in the workspaces or community or
other areas that um you inhabit
right it's not just about what how as
well
all right let's continue
and then i'll definitely come back to q
a
so something new this year is a my
stanford dodge
um my stanford dot mba dashboard and so
this is going to be able to
with a few short questions help collate
some of the events
that might be of interest to you so if
you have ongoing questions
um that could be a great place to engage
with us
and figure out what events coming down
the pipeline can help you along the
process
there is also a helpful tracker in as
you're applying to help you
know where in the process you are so
definitely check that out if you haven't
done so already
now i'm going to switch gears and we're
really going to focus on some of that q
a
i want to make sure that with the time
remaining that i'm able to be
as helpful for you on the call as
possible
ah here's a question from nikita i
always feel like everything i may
think matters to me may seem silly to
the admissions committee
and i i'm actually gonna reframe this
i'm gonna affirm
that that feeling could be real like for
you but i want to let you know from the
admission side that
if something matters to you then it
matters to us
if these are the things that really
drive and inform your desire
um to come to business school or these
are the things that inform
your set of values these are the things
we hope to
ask you about um one of the things that
i've come to really appreciate at the
gsb
is leadership is as much about
checking in with yourself and being able
to have
inner dialogue around things that might
feel very vulnerable
um and understanding how that impacts
the people around you
right and so it's as much of who you are
and
how does that influence the way you act
as it is
the actual action and distribution of
work itself
and so even though something might feel
kind of
sensitive and vulnerable um that does
not
undermine how important and how valuable
it can be
there's a lot um a
question here uh from um mammy
i've heard that the essay should be very
heartsy what does that really
mean and so i think it's continuing on
that theme
of um kind of it's okay to be vulnerable
that heartsy piece um for me means that
it's something that is meaningful for
you
there is a uh like a metaphor analogy
anecdote that um sometimes you'll hear
as a recommendation that like if you
write that essay and you print it out at
work and you left it on your printer
that you'd run back in the middle of the
night to go grab it
so that nobody else can see it i'd
actually like to step away from that
example
because it implies that you have to be
writing about
some something like secret or something
that might suggest that there is like
shame involved and that is definitely
not the purpose
of this essay it's about to help
think about um what are some of the
things that
are intrinsic to who you are
and so what i would like you to do
is as you're writing hopefully you have
some connection to what you're writing
about
maybe it is some kind of a sense of
protection or
privacy because it is something you
don't talk about that often
um sometimes it might be about something
that gives you a lot of joy
right because it's something that you
are very open about that you have been
working towards and
you want to be able to share that with
the world as long as you feel some kind
of connection
to that to whatever you're writing i
think you're headed on the right
direction
and so that would also go on top of
topic material so there is a theme of
questions there about
should it be personal professional so
what matters the most to you and why
essay
open doesn't have to be professional at
all again
about you impact questions the optional
ones
are gonna be asking about your impact in
a community
professional kind of one of the spaces
that you inhabit
for the why stanford again this is about
you
and this is where you can come back to
thinking about
given the things that you want to do how
is stanford going to help you get there
and this is going to be where you get a
little bit more to kind of your goals
and understanding what how the resources
at stanford
are going to assist you in achieving
whatever your vision might be
so hopefully that's a little bit of help
there
um there are also a couple of questions
here about finding mentors
to help with an essay and so there
are folks out there who offer their
services here
and we at the gsb
do not think that you need to
necessarily hire anybody or have
outside help to be successful in this
process
um if you are able to kind of put the
time
in have that self-reflection and write
um
and share with us who you are um we
think that's all it takes
definitely you can get feedback from
friends there are some organizations out
there like management leadership for
tomorrow or jumpstart that do
have mba prep programs that can assist
folks
through the process as they're
approaching business school um
kind of as a pathway
but you can do this on your own um and
this is and we do have we have
most of our folks are here like based
off of their work effort and the time
and investment that they put into the
process
okay some more questions here about the
what matters most
essay does an effective essay focus on
one topic
or can it include several i think
again here the decision rests with you
and i've seen it go both ways
another way that you can think about um
that several
category is if you do the that five
whys um is there a theme among those
things
that ties them together right or are
there other elements
to that that actually kind of help
inform like
a commonality so if you think there
might be several things
definitely you can talk about that but
that might also show that there's
deeper levels to dig into so again here
no right or wrong way to approach it
and so even though that might feel like
the biggest
like i'm gonna do a left turn on this
answer that's part of what makes the
essays
so amazing to be a part of is
to see the different ways that each one
of you kind of approaches the world
around you and what are the different
things that
have shaped who you are okay
question here about couple questions on
how much clarity
should applicants have about their
quote-unquote end-game or post-mba
career path
and so something that is often one of
those stereotypical
mba questions is what are your
short-term and long-term goals
and so definitely want you to consider
that
but the way we ask you that at the gsp
isn't necessarily in a full-blown essay
in and of itself we ask you that it's
kind of a short
few lines and so it's more about
what do you want to get out of business
school and what are your goals
and that's where the why stanford essay
comes into play
given the things that you want to do how
are we going to help
how are the resources at stanford going
to help you explore that
and so we on the admissions side are not
judging the um
how feasible your goals sound or whether
or not your past
body of work makes you eligible or
competitive for some future line of work
part of the beauty of business school is
the ability to
recognize potential to pivot to have new
opportunities and sometimes
opportunities that you never knew
existed
open up for you and we are not going to
hold you to
what you wrote in your essay but we want
to encourage you to be able to
tap into those opportunities as they
arise
and we want to be able to as an
institution equip you to be successful
regardless of where your professional
journey takes you both
industry-wise geography-wise
culture-wise
and so it's more about why do you want
to go to business school and how is it
going to help you along to
whatever it is you want to do
all right
okay here we go topics
all right let me go back to this q and a
box
so there was a question earlier about
the application material for interview
short listing or is it part of a final
assessment so for our interviews there
they are by invitation only
and so but that means that
once you finish your invitation we're
going to be taking a look at all of the
things that are submitted
including what you provided as well as
the write-up that your interviewer is
going to provide
it is a holistic review process so no
again no one part is necessarily more or
less
important than another but we want to
get a greater sense of
who you are throughout and so
everything you submit is going to be
used both as a way to understand
how we invite folks to the interview
process as well as who we invite into
the class
question here about do we evaluate
career how do we
evaluate career achievement by position
or by promotion
and even though this is more on the work
history side of it
um this might be another thing that
you're thinking about as you are
approaching the impact questions and so
here it's um more about giving the
opportunities
available to you how have you maximized
them
so we don't have a work history
requirement we don't have a work
experience requirement
it's more about given how long you are
or where you are in your career
what are some of the ways that you've
impacted the spaces around you
we know that folks who are applying out
of college or might be very early in
their career
might not have team leadership or
supervisory roles necessarily
but that doesn't mean you're not
displaying some of those
demonstrated leadership um elements uh
that
we find so interesting and so again
given where you are in your career
that's the context that we're
approaching it as
let's see question here about can you
share some of your favorite answers
themes topics that i have seen and so
i think the theme among some of
the essays that i thought really tackled
um
the gsb application kind of
in the full spirit of what we're asking
you to do are the ones that have dug
deep
it's not necessarily that these have had
to be
um either
like very like extremely sad stories
or something that has been out there
some of them have been on very
normal everyday topics but the way those
individuals have reflected on how the
how they relate to those topics and
how that shapes their perspective and
what this means for how they
their goals in the future those have
been some of the most i think
um the ones that have resonated the best
for me specifically
and then for the why stanford again it's
understanding
how the resources at the institution are
going to help you not just
what they are and listing off you know
here are
the classes i want to take but how is
that class
and that topic material or how is that
faculty member's expertise
going to assist you as you go on kind of
into the next steps
of your personal and professional career
so
those are the things the ones that where
people have really centered themselves
in the process and have been open and
honest about it throughout
people who have been able to dig deep
okay um question here from canuck how do
each of the short answers and essays fit
into your evaluation
again here holistic review process they
help us
understand more pieces about both your
context as well as potentially some of
those impact and ripple effects that you
might have had
and so there's folks who have described
it
as admissions as both a science and an
art
and given the flexibility and range that
you're able to cover
we want to be open to that again trying
to do our best to have that holistic
understanding of who you are
um see here we go
essay length okay here's a good question
so do you have any tips on how to cut
down on a long essay
how do you know if an essay is too long
or too short
and so we give guidance on you know the
maximum number of either characters or
words for any of our entries
and so we've found that you know you can
successfully convey your message
in um you know a pretty limited number
of words and i think also as you go on
into your career
i know this is something i struggle with
with emails it's how do you also convey
whatever is meaningful and important
kind of succinctly
and you can also think about this as an
exercise in that
um so if you step away from
the essay and you think about what is it
that i want
to tell them about myself take a look at
the essay you've written
and have you conveyed all of those
points
if you have take a critical eye are
there any like
extraneous elements here that feel like
they might be going off topic
have i strayed anywhere that could be
one place to think about editing
um and i know everybody has a very
different writing style
there is no right or wrong writing style
so
especially for the what matters most to
you essay some people have approached it
with a more
narrative style some have been a little
bit more
precise and organized again
you know how you write is also a piece
of who you are and so i don't want you
to
edit your written voice out
um but as you take a look on
that essay have you conveyed what you
want us to learn about you
adequately and that can give you a sense
there
so for the what matters most and the why
stanford essays
we give like a a guideline for
how many words for both and it's up to
you to decide between the two
like how you want to um use that the
real estate there
um the time when you think if an essay
is too short
is that is there something that you
haven't told us or
is there an opportunity to add that
detail in that space you just don't want
to let
um kind of real estate that could have
you utilized um to go to waste you don't
have to fill
every word but you also don't want to
have an essay that is like
half or less you know just to think
about it like you could have
there's a lot of room there to to let us
learn about you
okay question this is a good question
here a couple questions about avoiding
redundancy with the essay
should the essay be a chain in which
they can link together
other details or would you recommend
filling out the whole application first
to make sure the essay isn't repeating
information found
elsewhere i think there's multiple
strategies that have been suggested here
some folks might fill it out first go
through and then come back
um others might kind of piece things
together and do a little bit of plotting
to understand like take a look at the
application the different sections
and kind of understand where you want to
share different parts of
who you are with us there's no right or
wrong way here
i think regardless of which direction
you go
before you submit take a look at
everything that you've written i know i
hate rereading
anything i wrote but this is the time i
would really encourage you to take
to invest the time in doing so and as
you're looking through it
you know are you saying the same details
okay so
what are the takeaways are they
overlapping
or do they tell me something different
even if they're about like the same
project or topic
again you want to be able to use the
space thoughtfully and so
the subtext here start early give
yourself
enough time that you can go back
make revisions step back step away from
the computer and just think
or talk to those around you who you feel
safe and comfortable having these
conversations with
time is really the best gift you can
give yourself
so that at the end you feel good about
whatever it is you submitted
all right
okay there's a question here about being
told to write about an industry but not
sure what industry they want to be in
and so i think that's a very valid kind
of
realm to be open with so
it's less about do you happen to have a
specific
job industry title as it is you know
there are other
career goals that you might have that
might require
exploration and maybe part of business
school for you
is the ability to explore and get a
sense for
where within that space you might be
able to thrive the best or achieve
you know whatever it is that you wanted
to achieve in your career
that said at least have a vision know
why you're going to business school
and again as you tie it back to that why
stanford
how is the stanford experience going to
help you in that realm
right we don't want you to come to the
gsb and
there are so many opportunities at the
gsb and so many demands for your time
having that vision is going to be one of
those things that are going to help you
prioritize
to make sure you can maximize your two
years here
and so i think that's the other half of
that question is do you know what you're
going to be doing while you're here
not that you have you have to do those
things but having that north star
is going to be an incredibly powerful
tool
um as you embark on your two years at
stanford
all right maybe we have time for about
one or two more questions
uh let's see
ah here we go from natalie question oh
actually
natalie for your questions about letters
of recommendation i definitely recommend
checking out the ask an ao session this
friday
um we'd be happy to answer that one
their question was about kind of your
reference
letters and how do you talk to them
about like what to include
there's a lot of really great
information on our website as well
um so definitely check there there's
information both for you
as well as kind of some information for
the recommenders that you can actually
take a look at
as well
all right and here we go
any preference on so this is from missy
any preference on how the document is
structured
should we add the question at the top of
the page i believe the guidance was to
include
page numbers and have the essays in one
document any other tips for overall
presentation
and so really good question on the
tactical side i know we've covered a lot
like
the philosophical approach to the essays
and so here as long as it's clean as
long as it's readable
um i think that is the way to go
pretty standard text formatting is
useful
um i think one thing to consider is like
we are reading
a lot of essays and so that readability
is going to be important
um so that really is up to you we leave
that pretty open intentionally
um as long as you separate those two
essays and we have a sense for which
essay is which
i think you're on the right track there
so hopefully
the specific format and formatting is
not something that you have to worry
about
too much in the process all right we
have about
five minutes to go
and so here is a question that i think
is very
that will help us zoom back out towards
you know some of the takeaways that i
hope we're getting today and here's a
question about not having any
specific prior business experience in
business
and this question is from manassa and so
will not having any prior experience in
business management studies
impact have a negative impact on my
application or the admission process
and here i like to the answer is no
um there will be there's no negative
kind of consequence if you have not
studied business before
part of the beauty of the gsb
is that it's not just about business but
it's also about
leadership and it's about when you go
and as you're moving forward with your
career how are you going to
lead in the spaces that you're in
leaders come from all backgrounds
regardless of academic background
professional background
personal backgrounds that's where that
idea of diversity broadly defined
really comes into play and we have no
preference one way or the other
we would love to have the most broadly
diverse class as possible
all right here's one more hopefully a
quick one i know i go kind of long with
some of these
but any tips for approaching the
optional questions
um in parentheses there are questions
about the background perspective
and additional information section so um
for the background perspective and
perspective it we really do
ask very intentionally tell us about a
time in the last two years where
some element of who you are has
influenced the way kind of you you've
had an interaction
um and that is one of those moments that
you're able to step back and check in
with yourself
again to understand the hows and whys of
how you operate in the world
so very open on that side
as for additional information section
i know sometimes in your essays there
might be a circumstance that you're
trying to tell us about
and in the essay you might be focusing
more on the takeaways
but there might be contextual pieces
that are helpful or
maybe there's other elements of your
application that you want to explain to
us
maybe there was a health concern
during college that impacted your
classes or
um some kind of career trajectory that
might not seem intuitive at first but
you just want to give us a little bit
more detail about that so we understand
what was happening
that's where the additional information
come piece comes into play
if you aren't already talking about
these elsewhere
you can use additional information
section to let us know that information
um be succinct bullet points can work
and
it's not a place for another essay that
is not the purpose
and so we definitely don't call it
additional essay section
but any other contextual information
that you think is relevant for us to
know
that's going to be the place to do it
again holistic review process at
stanford
no one piece is more important or
weighted
more or less heavily than another we
really are trying to get a holistic
understanding and understanding of the
whole you
of how you're going to show up in our
classrooms and how you're going to show
up in our community
and so with that we are reaching the top
of the hour thank you so much for
joining us
um for this very first um webinar
on the application and the stanford
essays
so as you go forward i hope you're able
to take the time to reflect
um and really understand the things that
motivate you to move forward
as you start to unpack and untangle some
of the things that
kind of inform the way you move through
the world hopefully that also gives you
some of the tools
to be able to stand with and appreciate
those around you
with so much more depth and nuance and
in doing so
hopefully you'll also be able to come to
appreciate
and value the opportunity that the
diversity
of the world around you has to offer so
as you go forward with the rest of this
week i hope you are able to attend
sessions that you find inspiring and
invigorating
um and as you go on to write your
application or fill out your application
write your essays
feel good about it have fun if it's at
all possible enjoy the process and i
believe in you